hello everyone and welcome to Round four
of the 2019 Greinke chess classic we
already seen three games played by
Vincent Kaymer fourteen-year-old prodigy
from Germany and the inrun one he faced
Magnus Carlsen vulture champion then he
faced with Martin Allen and then Fabiana
Caruana so definitely tough three rounds
and now faces are cut in I did she has
the black pieces and it's well it's
really an impressive game one that
really you know anyone could have played
and it could have turned out either way
but without further ado let's just check
out the game we don't we don't have any
photos the it was a pretty quick game so
the the Greinke just classic video team
didn't have the time to upload them for
me to use but we will be showing more
games from this round so if you're not
we will have some nice footage and some
nice photos so without further ado we
have
efore by arkady knowledge vincent
replies with c5 so the Sicilian defense
is on the board and now nice to see 390
goes for the closed system with a six
and now Knight G - E - yeah with d6 by
Vincent and now a for preventing
expansion by b5 on the Queen side Knight
to f6 by Vincent g3 preparing to
fianchetto the light square bishop we
have Knight to c6 Vincent keeps on
developing pieces push up to g2 and here
already on move six we have a new game
on our hands east six was played g6 is a
known move there is one game where g6
was played but after east six we have
now a completely new game so Cain I
teach castles and we have Bishop to e7
Vincent is also ready to castle with f4
and Vincent castles and d3 now so you
can see that white really controls a lot
of space in the center but also black
doesn't fall behind and well white the
pawn structure in front of the White
King is a bit loosened up so if if
things don't go well this should be
advantage for black but okay rook to b8
a nice developing move by the road
preparing b5 getting the rook out of
this nasty diagonal and the a8 square h3
taking away the g4 Square from the black
night preparing King to g2 King to h2
and
also preparing g4 as night which is
going for a very aggressive opening line
Knight to d7 and the now comes g4 so the
night is already on the 7 g5 will not
count with tempo we have h6 and then out
comes nice to g3 so you can see that
white really is putting a lot in this
attack and night it she really had to
decide which opening to use against
Vincent because he saw that Vincent is
really a deadly opponent and you can
just play anything he knows or Vincent
knows his opening theory you know unlike
capablanca and you have to really try
hard to get any edge even out of the
opening rush up to h4 by Vincent and now
Knight c2e2 just Rema nuvaring regarding
tonight on g 3 and B 5 everything is
taken care of on the kingside tsunamis
and has time to grab space on the Queen
side with King to h2 and now as a white
did not react to this pawn push b4 we
have Bishop to e3
just a nice developing move and a5 now
Vincent locks the the Queen side here
Queen to d2 with some ideas of maybe in
the future pushing f5 and sacrificing on
h6 but just Bishop to a6
again a nice square for the light square
bishop as you're not gonna be developing
it over here so but b3 not allowing any
more pawn push controlling the c-4
square and here Queen to e7 just
developing the Queen connecting rooks
and rook the g1 here Knight is again
transferring all of his pieces over to
the King side the rook 8 f1 is coming
and then he is considering pushing some
of some of his pawns depending on what
black plays rook beat the c8 by Vincent
and now comes Luke 8 f1s planned
we have g6 preventing f5 and now comes C
5 and here you have an option you can
either capture or push the d5 pawn
whatever you do Knight its next move is
it's completely the same so Vincent
decided to push d5 and here we have
f5 so it's a very interesting moment a
very aggressive moment in the game you
are vincent climber of 2700
master Arkady night is coming for you
with everything he has all of his pieces
are very aggressively placed so feel
free to pause the video here and you
know just soak in the position and try
to figure out how you would go about
this position with the black pieces I'll
give you a couple of seconds as usual
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you were an excellent
defender this is one of those positions
where we really have to take it easy and
realize that White's attack isn't all
that scary as it seems but it's that's
easier said than done of course now
after the game it's easy to say things
like that but when you're faced with a
move like a five you know you're really
getting nervous you start wasting time
and it's really you have to train
yourself well to play well in positions
like these so here Vincent played Knight
captures on e5 but there was a better
idea just g5 and here it's a very very
aggressive line f6 pushing the Queen
back Queen to d8 and now Bishop captures
on d5 this is the line you had to see
it's a it's a standard idea of course if
pawn characters Knight comes to a5 now
you're gonna capture on h6 is just a
really tough position to play with black
so of course you will not capture the
bishop the point was after this Bishop
captures on d5 you have to go Knight
captures on e5 and now the bishop just
looks silly on d5 you have to play the
Bushra back to g2 or h1 and now after
Knight captures on f6 you've completely
prevented the white from attacking and
now you can start your counter-attack so
this was the way the correct way to go
about this but Vincent did not find this
g5 idea he went Knight see captures on
e5 maybe he thought of going g5 next but
of course knowledge will not allow that
he goes Bishop captures on h6 first you
have to react as your rook is under
attack we have look after I ate and now
as the rock no longer occupies the F
I'll just F captures on g6 with F
captures on g6 and now g5 just a
grabbing control of D of the f6 squared
the knight will find a very nice outpost
there and also the bishop now is unable
to retreat
so here what you want to do is play
continue playing on the queenside as the
white still doesn't have any decisive
threat on the kingside you want to play
c4 and after D captures Bishop captures
on g3 first a nice in-between move and
after Knight captures D captures on c4
and here white would still go for his
attack nice to e4 he would threaten
Knight to f6 and still it would be very
hard to hold this but it would be black
the best bet
so after g5 vincent didn't go for this
vincent played nice to f7 but here it's
just a a very tough position for Black
Knight it immediately found Queen to f4
he went for the bishop here and you can
either decide to give it up by Bishop
captures on g3 or you can capture on h6
vincent captured an h6 now if you
capture the Queen will once again guard
the bishop but Knight each is not
interested in that he plays Queen
captures on h4 and now it's again not
easy to decide what to do vincent played
Knight to f7 but it is the best move if
you go for something like Knight to f5
then you get the rook captures on f5
this is the problem and after G captures
and now you get to Knight captures on f5
and you're either gonna fall apart this
way or if you just capture then you're
gonna get Bishop captures and now any
move by the King is losing but the
easiest way to lose would be King g7 and
Queen h6 this would be checkmate as the
bishop is controlling the light squares
the Queen slices over this way this way
and this way and of course this is
checkmate
so after Queen to h4 grabbing the bishop
Vincent that went back Knight to f7 and
now a powerful move by NIDA you could go
for the slow Knight to f4 attack but
Knight is just playing really a
beautiful attacking game just Knights to
h5 he immediately wants to go to f6 to
win the game and you have to react to
this now there are a few ways you could
do this you could avoid it to capture
play something like Queen b6 with check
after King moves just move the rook rook
a faith not allow your piece to be
captured but this would still be losing
just check and now you would have to
capture pawn captures and now the threat
of course is not that as the knight is
still covering the square but you can
just go tonight's the night Stewie five
after
black moves nah comes Knight to f4
piling up on the g6 bone and after let's
say rook to c7 guarding the h7 square
you can go Queen g5 and now there's no
defense Knight captures on g6 it's
coming and Blackpool again fall apart
so after this knife to h5 move Vincent
decided to capture it we have pawn
captures here and here
again a very interesting position that
really deserves maybe even more if he
had but I'll still think about it I feel
free to pause the video again and try to
find how to precisely continue this
attack with the white pieces I'll again
give you a couple of seconds for those
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent lifter of rooks and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show rook to f6 this is the idea this is
what an iTouch played if you just play
something like Queen captures here it's
very easy to defend you go back 96 now
you're gonna read maneuver the night
over to f5 and after a white brings the
knight into the game now just go Knight
a5 if Queen g6 check you just block and
everything as well here and III do
believe after G captures that this
deserves a morphe head so we're just
gonna do it and there it is mr. Morpheus
here rook to f6 and here how do you
defend not not not gonna be easy so what
do you do the best thing well it's not
the best but it could prove to be the
most resistant idea is just against c4
plan the Queen side there is no decisive
threat just yet on the Kings side and
after Knight to f4 C capture son b3 now
you can go Queen captures on h5 and now
Knight to f8 I just bring everything in
into the defense and now g6 where it's
still a a really crazy line you would
have to move the night and then suffer
slowly whites whites building up attack
or if you capture the rook then you
would immediately in the game with pawn
captures here and after Queen captures
now you just use the rook on g1 Bishop
captures on d5 opening up a discovered
check you would have to give up your
queen or something captures captures and
then it would be an easy victory for
white so after loop to f6 events and
decided to capture it we have Knight
captures
now comes pawn captures attacking the
Queen Queen goes back while delivering
Czech Queen d6 check and now Knight to
f4 just blocking check and still your
king occupies the G file if the bishop
moves it will be very unpleasant for
example if you try a slow move just
Bishop f3 is sufficient this comes with
check and after the King moves the
bishop captures here not a lot you can
do here just the Bishop captures is
coming through g6 check King will have
to go back and Queen h8 checkmate it's
well whatever black plays will end in
checkmate
so after Knight to f4 Vincent decided to
move back into a faith now no
discoveries are possible but Queen to g3
a very nice move just lining up the
Queen and the rook to go to g8 and also
if Knight to g6 check then you can see
that the queen is not defendant D says
this would also win the Queen so Vincent
goes rook it to d8 now the Queen is
defended but also the King now has an
escape route
hopefully rook to e1 now the rook no
longer guards the e6 pawn so now the e6
pawn becomes weak the knight and rook
are both attacking it with E 5 by
Vincent and now finally Knight to g6
check and still a very tough position if
you go back with the King J 1097 check
whatever you do king of faith Queen
Queen g8 will be checkmate or if you go
King to EA twitch happened in the game
then comes Knight captures on e5 a
deadly idea again
if Vincent would capture then rocky 5
check King d7 and now of course rook
captures on d5 the bishop is controlling
the d5 square wins the Queen and the
game and it's not even yeah you could
claim that ok I have two queen two rooks
for the Queen but not not really after
black makes a move we're just gonna push
f7 and the f7 pawn is such a nice bone
in your throat you're not gonna be able
to activate the rooks at all you could
go something like Ruby 8 hope hope to
get Ruby 6 in but it's not gonna happen
just Queen g6 then Queen 6 Queen c6
becomes possible and the rooks have no
moves so after Knight captures on e5
Vincent tried Queen captures on f6 he
got rid of this very annoying pawn
for the third time and the last time in
this game pause the video and try to
find the quickest way to end this for
mr. Murphy had an idea I'll give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent you know discover or
creator of nasty discoveries let's go
with that and for those who just wanna
enjoy Knight g4 is the best discovery
now you're threatening to win the Queen
just Knight captures here and if Quint
a7 which happened in the game not
capturing the Queen but just Knight to
f6 checked the Queen cannot capture as
the queen is pinned the knife controls
d7 check out the king you have to move
the King back and the game didn't
continue it was in this position unmoved
36 before reaching time control that
Vincent Kaymer resigned the game what if
you resign well it's mating one after
King to a fate just Queen g8 checkmate
no way to avoid this and yes an
excellent attacking game by mr. Murphy
head are cutting I ditch we can lose
that now so really a beautiful attacking
game a masterpiece attacking game if you
will and it all comes down to this
moment where this f5 move was played
where you really have to figure out how
to go about this Vincent didn't go about
it precisely
he should have played g5 and everything
is everything is well but again like I
said that's much easier said and done
when you're playing when such a strong
Grandmaster is coming for you plays a 5
it's you know yeah everything everything
and anything can go wrong and in this
game it did go wrong for for young
Vincent sure after this Knight of 6
check what a wonderful ending position
it might even use this for a thumbnail
who knows I've Instant Karma resigned
the game and an excellent victory for
our kaolinite each but as I said we will
be showing more games from this round
and I'm expecting some footage and some
nice photos so we're gonna be showing
the standings then as well I would like
to thank Simon Johansen Lucas Williams
TT Moriarty Gugu Marquis volver volver
de and the David Compton for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check you on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the Greinke just classic and
well whatever I come up if I come up
with more time I will try to do
something else as well
I think you'll I will see soon and have
an excellent rest of your day